the woman that we got who plays Gladys  she came on and just started improving  whatever she was saying and it was  unbelievable there's a little last  minute video that happens okay and so  Gladys can you just get out there and  get us started please I'll try yeah well  don't try just do okay you've been  snipping at me all morning  [Applause]  so that is uh May Laborde I played  Gladys she was born on May 13 1909 and  she started her acting career at the age  of 93. and the the absolute Pinnacles  her flipping through the pages when D  sings her own song and saying what is  happening what is happening best  delivery of one of our most iconic lines  that we've written into a thousand  episodes  we don't have time for like disco time  [Laughter]  look how much fun  what a delight